foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
technology entertainment design holy
[ __ ] okay that place the piece was
called once there were three and it came
from the brain of nina mcneely who is
here and i'm gonna invite her for that
standing oh if you don't mind nina
please take the stage take your moment
take your bow
okay
okay nina i have a few questions for you
i know that you don't always want to
speak that your work speaks for itself
but nonetheless thank you for joining me
up here
so you are a visual artist a
choreographer and an animator and
somehow you're bringing everything
together what are you doing you're
blending technology and dance what's
happening
yes um i've always been intrigued by
the human experience the world of dreams
and whatever may be lurking in the
shadows of the subconscious mind so i
use dance to tell stories about
sisterhood and struggle and
transcendence
and i combine that with live projection
mapping to create surrealist
environments that i can shift in and out
of quickly so it feels just like a dream
and it also allows me to create
illusions
that the dancers are controlling the
animations with their bodies
tell us a little bit about the pres
there's a lot of precision here what's
actually what's going on
well this piece was actually um
commissioned by entity contemporary
dance in los angeles as a film and this
is the first time it's ever been
performed live first time
oh my god that's so awesome
um so my process always starts with
music music is like a psychedelic to me
so i'm always searching for music that's
going to take me on the most imaginative
journey possible
and then i envision the piece i set the
choreography on the dancers i shoot that
choreography usually with my phone
and then i bring that into my animation
software i create the animations then we
get back in the studio and combine the
two together which actually takes hours
and hours of trial and error
and uh i heavily rely on the impeccable
music timing of my dancers and their
talent and precision they're amazing so
i love that you brought up music tell us
about the music that we just heard so
this music was composed by an artist
named umro with a feature by another
artist named warpster
and i found umer's music on soundcloud
around five years ago
and was just blown away by his use of
these visceral crunchy sounds combined
with these angelic vocal samples and i
really loved that his music sounded both
ancient and futuristic at the same time
so i started choreographing to his music
in my dance class and we started talking
on instagram and the collaboration was
born
so this session is all about imagination
tell us a little bit about your creative
process and how imagination clearly
plays into that
um so at this point in my career as an
artist i've decided to just let my
influences flow into me without question
even if they're not on trend or
unpopular and this music really struck
me with these visions of the religious
iconography i was exposed to growing up
in the catholic church
and because of my mexican and filipino
heritage that imagery was intense
a little bloody
and dramatic
and i just remember being surrounded by
these paintings and figurines
whose faces expressed such sorrow and
piety and ecstasy
and i just remember being completely
awestruck and put in the state of pure
childlike wonderment by their beauty and
darkness
and it's my greatest desire to recreate
that experience and share it with the
world were you sure did that nina
mcneely thank you
[Applause]